[Music]
in the struggles real news
hey yeah yeah submitted by tiger stop
stop growing yes please take up your
watching just stop right now what you
want how did you say anything like that
want to stop his natural process because
he's cute as [ __ ] right now these day
baby says forever
so you want to meanie me yeah I like
that he's crying it looks cool the other
day I saw his foot I'm like what I
thought it was like this but it's like
this I told you right this morning I was
like he ain't got the marshmallow feet
no more she's got a flat foot now
without having I just looks like a big
marshmallow foot it's a spam musubi now
yeah yeah
an Amazon worker is posting videos of
how she became homeless after getting
injured on the job
what why is she homeless I mean that
must be a bad injury if you could be
homeless now don't you get workers I
don't think for Amazon cuz you're a
contractor really hard core is funky
well if you're deliver or whatever I
think the way that it's set up it's a
you're kind of on for your own is this a
contractor or she Alok don't quote me on
that yeah I don't know I thought it was
the delivery people's I just made up
that part myself so she was injured when
the station that she was working on it
was missing a piece of safety equipment
that's designed to stop items from
falling onto the floor she hurt herself
while using a tote bin as a temporary
replacement and then she was also doing
it like in a really awkward position
was it three separate separate incidents
or was this all like three things that
happen at once it sounds like she was
lifting something and then tweet you
back well I guess like she was pulling
items but the equipment that she was
using it's supposed to have this like
this thing where it catches the items
from falling but instead of having that
thing it was like a plastic bin and
supposed to be there like that somehow
like she was working like she was
counting items in the awkward position
absolutely a point is that the piece of
equipment that they had was faulty so
it's their fault that she got injured
that's not fair
she didn't sue or anything to get money
or
the thing is though Amazon did give her
medical attention like they sent her to
a doctor but every day that she would go
to see the doctor they would dismiss her
without pay while she was still unable
to work and she was dealing with that
for nine months
damn as long as management only offered
her just one week of paid leave they
also offered her a buyout for three
thousand five hundred which meant that
she would have to sign an NDA not talk
about all of this so she declined that
because she wanted it
we know her story damn
Amazon sounds gangster as [ __ ] that's
how bad Jeff bezel is number one now
right yes we've been saying it in the
video too she's like I can't believe
this is my life now I work for the
world's richest man and now now I live
in my car I'm gonna show you guys a
small clip of her wonderful videos her
name is Vicky she's 49 years old that's
true because I haven't heard any
Microsoft scandals and Bill Gates just
kind of stayed number one for a long
time there's been some that I'm at
Amazon parking lot still living in my
car there's another guy you see that car
sitting right over there
he's also sleeping in his car now I
don't know if he lives here or not but I
just can't believe this is my life now
just I I just can't believe it I mean
I'm just I live in my car
at my job who does that who does that
all because they wanted to cancel me off
workers compensation the day before my
MRI and send me back to work full duty
yes full duty and so I hired an attorney
which this is in litigation now because
I'm fighting to get back on workers
compensation so I can get my back taken
care of my injury that I sustained
working at this [ __ ] on their faulty
equipment I mean I am one of thousands
of stories out there that are just like
this I'm sad do you know what sucks is
on like the business side of things like
the business owners side as well as the
employee side is in the past there has
been examples of exploitation of the
system on both parties so people have to
like deal with this situation in such a
[ __ ] up like cautionary yeah it's like
you can't just be honorable on both ends
anymore look I'm so sick and tired of
people taking advantage of billionaires
like these it's not easy it's so
stressful to be a billionaire you can
imagine what it's like to have [ __ ]
assassins trying to kill you instead are
just a regular business owner who gets
[ __ ] over from people exploiting the
system you know and suing and all that
I've heard of that I guess I've heard of
that but I'm telling you this lady right
here
does something not right about it man
something about her tone of her voice
I'm like nah man she's just trying to
rip off a billionaire again somebody
trying to do that because people that
specifically go in
and they scan the system and they get
injured so people they have to do this
where they like fire and [ __ ] people
over because they're afraid of getting
exploited one of my favorite things on
YouTube is videos of people like trying
to slip and fall shits great the Russian
ones are the best ones so this one guy
she was on a bicycle and then he stopped
and he got off the bicycle and he threw
the bicycle and he went like this off
this I love this [ __ ]
there's 1/2 of a guy it's I think a
Russian one where the guy's driving and
he's got a dashcam and then some guy
like runs in the street and just like so
it was great and then the guy like he
points to the dashcam
and the guys like oh it's amazing
have you seen the more people have these
water bottles with the pool and the in
the grocery store oh yeah why can't just
let not like look like you're not in a
Buster Keaton movie dude like who does
this [ __ ] like if you're gonna slip make
it count and have your like upper lip
get caught in like a chip rack or
something sort of fetus splits open and
make it believable it's true dude grab a
[ __ ] rag and take it down you're
grabbing the air like it's gonna do
something we all know you're [ __ ]
acting when you I've seen better acting
in the NBA where people like they're
trying to take a charging call and they
get hit and they're like a flag all the
way back dude any soccer game the soccer
games are great yeah they fall on the
ground you see the eyes are wandering
eyes like right did you see that
they don't even get hit at all and then
they fall in the ground and then they
pointed a guy that's the best know when
they are in court for this [ __ ] like for
the groceries who are slipping in on
stuff they the judge should be like
really that was like they should get
physical comedians to come in and rape
yes did I hey man that was that was
pretty funny like okay you should get it
you see it away with it like I like that
I would be for that do you think that
would be fair just just if they do a
good job of acting yeah well with
cameras nowadays have you ever lied
about something and then you're pissed
off that nobody believes you and so you
double down on the lie just because I'm
saying it's only during mafia yeah
you're faking sick and then and then
people don't believe you and then you're
the cop the cop whenever you call in
sick yeah I'm sick haha like you gotta
add those cops in there why is that
cuz you're guilty you're nervous you're
[ __ ] guilty you're grabbing you're
trying to grab the air it's the same
[ __ ] cuz when people are saying you
don't have to [ __ ] calm not have to
like when you're really sick you you
could sound normal I'm just sick I don't
feel good hell yeah I noticed that
everybody else did it too and I was like
oh [ __ ] that's [ __ ] stupid yeah my
[ __ ] was just like my [ __ ] when I was
going to school when I was a kid was the
whole like I don't feel good to get that
smart yeah that's different
like the Mel Gibson just smoked the
whole thing a secret I just tried a dog
Rhonda I really don't feel good today
mom
it's a crackle thing it's like Oh Steve
and your voice is not good now I know I
think it's okay if you show your making
effort then it's that much more
believable now I really want to go to
school this week I'm so excited about it
I try to do that every day you know
you're just gonna have to wait till next
week all the time I try to do it every
day every dance I think I'm sick today
to check my temperature every day I had
to [ __ ] put that [ __ ] in my mouth
I was actually sad when I was held the
hot water [ __ ] put that in there I
wanted to sit home and watch Sesame
Street dude [ __ ] that I try to do
everything to not go to school I think
one time I reached it and I actually got
pneumonia oh no and I was like [ __ ] that
I was trying my best to get some kind of
disease I could stay home you're like
rusty [ __ ] and [ __ ] the bottom of
your feet I was trying to be sick so I
could stay home watch TV all day I'll
pull the covers over man like 15 minutes
before my mom comes everything up so I
heat the [ __ ] up yeah and I try to get
my head head all hot and I [ __ ] like
rub it like this and [ __ ] pretty good
perfection going oh yeah yeah and those
are good and then she she oh my god it's
so hot Stephen oh my god thankfully she
wouldn't do it again like two minutes
later that's how I gotta live it oh hell
back for a gear because I did this [ __ ]
really well yeah you really held back
yeah cuz my parents like he's not ready
to go at school he's just getting sick
whole time he's probably not interested
to stay home and watch TV I was like
before I went into kindergarten
dang I was a full year older than
everybody at school and your pilot oh oh
yeah so yeah when I graduated I was like
nineteen everyone's a teen who's sick I
was trying to do that
I actually had pneumonia and I spent a
week in the hospital and they put IV
through me hell yeah and it was way back
it was way better than school like I
really try laid their high like a [ __ ]
hundred and three fever and like Oh dad
these culture isn't shale ideal I was
coughing up crazy phlegm and like water
out of my head alone yeah I don't know
how I got it but that was way better
than school whatever experience that I
don't even know how I got it either it's
when you have some sort of liquid in
your lungs oh yeah my dad will come and
visit me at the hospital my mom would
come and visit him it was like I felt
like I had control like I get to let you
guys come in my room outside they say
that kids that get sick a lot and do all
that stuff it's cuz they got some [ __ ]
going on at home oh that's probably what
it was I had a Super Nintendo control
that's how you control you just say you
felt control and [ __ ] baby I was like
I'm sick mom take care of me yeah [ __ ]
yeah well you just made something funny
really [ __ ] sad dude it's still funny
what are you talking about you're funny
yeah oh it was hilarious I'm glad you're
coping with it however that's [ __ ]
sad the dirtiest uh funniest is for you
[ __ ] 3d and if I forgot but [ __ ] I
would be sharing that story on every
single Elvis and I'd be laughing yeah
like we don't know the story where Bobby
Lee got molested by a special person
with Down syndrome
that's hilarious alright we'll see you
guys next week
that's weird I love molestation stories
all right we'll see you guys
[Music]